10 Amazing Actors Who Show Up In Multiple
Superhero Movies
Superhero movies are currently some of the
most popular and successful in Hollywood.
As a result, more and more of them are getting
released every year.
Because of that, actors are inevitably turning
up in more than one of them and playing multiple
characters.
In some cases, you'll notice obvious similarities
between the different characters a single
actor has played, but the most interesting
thing is seeing just how different some of
them are.
For example, one actor in this video has played
both a disfigured western bounty hunter and
a monstrous alien warlord.
Although this is by no means an exhaustive
list, let's a take a look at some of the best
examples of this; Here are 10 amazing actors
who show up in multiple superhero movies.
Chris Evans
Having first appeared as a Marvel character
in Fox's terrible Fantastic Four movies, you
would think Chris Evans would have stayed
away from the Marvel Cinematic Universe, but
his role as the Human Torch in 2005's Fantastic
Four and 2007's Fantastic Four: Rise of the
Silver Surfer hasn't prevented him from making
a success of his more recent role as Captain
America.
Evans has played the super soldier - also
known as Steve Rogers - in no less than seven
movies to date, including cameos and credits
scenes.
The role started with 2011's Captain America:
The First Avenger and, most recently, has
seen Evans star in this year's Captain America:
Civil War.
It should also be noted that he played computer
hacker Jake Jensen in 2010's The Losers, alongside
the aforementioned Idris Elba.
Ben Affleck
There's no denying that Ben Affleck is a very
talented actor, but back in 2003 his reputation
took a really hard hit.
Affleck played the title character, Matt Murdock,
in Daredevil and was almost universally panned
for his portrayal of the superhero.
In fact, 2003 was the year he won the Golden
Raspberry Award for Worst Actor for his performances,
which also included roles in Gigli and Paycheck.
More recently, however, he portrayed the iconic
Dark Knight, Batman, in 2016's Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice.
His initial casting was met with anger, but
his eventual performance won over the fans
pretty emphatically, and the world is looking
forward to seeing him in the role again in
the future.
Idris Elba
Multi-talented British actor, musician and
DJ, Idris Elba, is best-known for his performance
in TV shows like The Wire and Luther - but
he's also appeared in multiple superhero movies.
Elba has portrayed the all-seeing Asgardian
Heimdall in three Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies to date; 2011's Thor, 2013's Thor:
The Dark World and 2015's Avengers: Age of
Ultron.
But he also played a French priest by the
name of Moreau in 2013's Ghost Rider: Spirit
of Vengeance, as well as the explosives expert,
Roque, in 2010's The Losers (which isn't really
a "superhero" movie, but is based on a Vertigo
Comics title).
Josh Brolin
Goonies star Josh Brolin has starred as two
very different comic book movie characters
in two very different movie franchises - and
the first is a role he probably regrets.
He played the title character in 2010's Jonah
Hex - a movie in which even a stellar cast
couldn't prevent it from being awful.
More recently, he has portrayed the big-bad
Thanos in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
To date, he has appeared in 2014's Guardians
of the Galaxy and in the mid-credits scene
of 2015's Avengers: Age of Ultron.
He will have a more prominent part to play
as the Mad Titan in future movies – and
we can’t wait to see that.
Tommy Lee Jones
Veteran actor Tommy Lee Jones is another star
who has played both good guys and bad guys
in superhero movies.
First, he portrayed the iconic Batman villain
known as Two-Face in 1995's Batman Forever
- a movie in which the villains were the only
characters worth talking talking about.
More recently, he played Colonel Chester Phillips
- Steve Rogers' commanding officer - in 2011's
Captain America: The First Avenger.
He's also famously played Agent K in three
Men in Black movies - a franchise that you
might not know was actually based on a Marvel
Comics property.
J.K. Simmons
The incredibly talented, Academy Award-winning
actor J.K. Simmons brilliantly portrayed the
Daily Bugle's editor-in-chief J. Jonah Jameson
in Sam Raimi's Spider-Man trilogy.
His performance as Jameson was genuinely iconic
and he was undoubtedly the best thing in 2002's
Spider-Man, 2004's Spider-Man 2 and 2007's
Spider-Man 3.
For his next role in a superhero movie, we're
going to have to look to the future.
Simmons was recently cast as Commissioner
James Gordon in the DC Extended Movie Universe
and he will debut as the character in 2017's
Justice League Part One.
How exciting is that?!
James Marsden
James Marsden's most prominent role in a superhero
franchise is undoubtedly that of Scott Summers
AKA Cyclops.
Cyclops is the field leader of the X-Men and
Marsden has played the character in four movies
to date; those being 2000's X-Men, 2003's
X2: X-Men United, 2006's X-Men: The Last Stand
and 2014's X-Men: Days of Future Past.
Marsden also played Richard White - the nephew
of the Daily Planet's editor-in-chief Perry
White and fiancé to Lois Lane - in 2005's
Superman Returns.
Halle Berry
Academy Award-winning actress Halle Berry
has played Ororo Munroe - the weather-controlling
mutant also known as Storm - in four X-Men
movies to date.
They happen to be the same four movies as
the aforementioned James Marsden and, like
Marsden, it doesn't look like she'll be reprising
the role any time soon.
Berry also has the unwanted distinction of
playing the lead in arguably the worst superhero
movie ever made.
2004's Catwoman was a complete trainwreck
of a movie, and Berry's Patience Phillips
was a truly awful and unfaithful adaptation
of a classic comic book character.
Jim Carrey
The hilarious and multi-talented Jim Carrey
has actually played characters in no less
than three different superhero franchises.
Starting with 1994's The Mask, Carrey portrayed
the title character - also known as Stanley
Ipkiss - in a year that really propelled him
to superstardom.
A year later, he starred alongside the aforementioned
Tommy Lee Jones in Batman Forever.
Like Jones, Carrey also played a villain - The
Riddler in his case - and he did so to near-perfection.
Most recently, he played Colonel Stars and
Stripes in 2013's Kick-Ass 2 - a movie he
famously and controversially retracted support
for, due to the level of violence it depicted
in the wake of the tragic Sandy Hook shootings.
Ryan Reynolds
Ryan Reynolds has become fairly prolific in
the world of superhero movies, having appeared
as three - or you could even say four - different
characters in four very different movies.
First of all, he played the cocky vampire
hunter Hannibal King in 2004's Blade: Trinity,
then he played the cocky mercenary Wade Wilson
in 2009's X-Men Origins: Wolverine, then he
played the cocky pilot Hal Jordan in 2011's
Green Lantern and, finally, he played a different
version of the cocky mercenary Wade Wilson
in 2016's Deadpool - are you noticing a trend
here?
Thanks for watching our list of 10 amazing
actors who show up in multiple superhero movies.
Did you know about all of these?
Did we leave any major examples out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!